warum gehen plötzlich tausende junge
Frauen und Männer im Iran auf die Straße
es beginnt alles mit einem tragischen
Tod der Tod von Mascha Amini einer
22-jährigen Frau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mutige Frauen im Iran verbrennen ihre
Kopftücher das Zeichen jahrzehntelanger
Unterdrückung es geht in Flammen auf es
sind Bilder die um die Welt gehen
seit zwei Wochen gehen Menschen im Iran
auf die Straße sind Männer und Frauen in
Aufruhr Frauen schneiden sich aus
Protest die Haare ab
Auslöser ist der gewaltsame Tod von
Mascha Amini die 22-Jährige war Mitte
September von den iranischen
Sittenwächtern festgenommen worden weil
ihr Kopftuch angeblich nicht richtig saß
nach ihrer Verhaftung fällt Mascha Amini
plötzlich ins Koma stirbt kurz darauf im
Krankenhaus
seit ihrem Tod Gerät das islamistische
müller-regime immer stärker unter Druck
überall im Land gehen Iranerinnen und
Iraner auf die Straße wütende Proteste
in mindestens 46 stellten mutige
Proteste gegen die Unterdrückung gegen
das unterdrückerische müller-regime
brutale Härte gehen die
Sicherheitskräfte gegen die
Freiheitskämpfer vor schlagen auf sie
ein Schießen mit scharfer Munition in
die Menge
verhaften tausende schalten das Internet
im Land ab um den Protest
niederzukämpfen die brennenden
Kopftücher im Iran sie sind ein
eindrucksvolles Symbol für den mutigen
Kampf gegen das islamistische Regime
[Applaus]
den Kampf für die Freiheit bezahlen
viele mit dem Leben bislang soll es
mindestens 76 Tote geben
der Kampf gegen jahrzehntelange
Unterdrückung weckt auch die Hoffnung
dass das müller-regime ins Wanken gerät
was dies der Anfang vom Ende ist das
Ende der autoritären mullermachthaber in
Teheran
und über dieses Thema sprechen wir jetzt
mit bildreporterin Schami AK hier bei
uns im Studio schönen guten Tag Schami
du kommst aus Bangladesch dort gibt es
eine muslimische Mehrheitsgesellschaft
welche Erfahrung hast du mit
muslimischen Kleidungsvorschriften
machen müssen ich bin in Bangladesch in
einer sehr praktikalischen islamischen
Gesellschaft geboren und aufgewachsen in
meinem meinen 21
Lebensjahren würde ich mehrmals auf der
Straße verbal und körperlich angegriffen
weil ich nicht angemessene Kleidung
getragen habe vor allem weil ich kein
Zug getragen habe du berichtest jetzt
schon seit mehreren Tagen über die
Proteste im Iran würdest du sagen dass
das eine frauenrevolution Gerade ist die
da stattfindet es ist die größte
feministische Bewegung unserer Zeit ich
habe nie so was erlebt in meinem in
meiner journalistischen Karriere und
wenn man die
dass die Fotos anschau anschaut es ist
es ist so mutig die Frauen ist jetzt
schon mehr als 70 Frauen Männer sogar
Kinder sind schon tot Cordon gehen die
Frauen auf die Straße sie wollen die
FREIHEIT obwohl sie wissen sie können
ihrer Zeit getötet werden können und ich
finde ja es ist eine frauenrevolution
viele in Deutschland sagen bei den
Protesten im Iran geht es nicht gegen
den Islam sondern nur um Grundrechte und
Freiheit sie behaupten es aber nichts
mit dem Islam zu tun wie bewertest du
das doch es ist es ist der Islam es geht
um den richtigen Islam die Frage ist
woher hat die iranische moralpolizei
diese Vorstellung zum Moral bekommen das
kommt aus einer bestimmten Religion das
kommt aus Islam das müssen wir laut auch
erwähnen und sagen und vor allem wir
müssen an Fakten schauen gerade wenn das
Kopftuch fällt fallen die mullers wenn
die iranischen Frauen
frei sind ist das gesamte Volk auch frei
wir haben es gerade eben gesagt
iranspräsident raisi kündigt an Gesetze
möglicherweise reformieren zu wollen was
sagst du dazu
ich glaube nicht ein Reform werde gerade
in im Iran möglich ich glaube gerade die
iranische Frauen die unten
internationale Unterstützung vor allem
diese feministische Außenpolitik dort
muss Einsatz eingesetzt werden was
forderst du konkret was würde helfen
Sankt Sohn wir müssen die mullers
isolieren Samsung und diese
feministische Außenpolitik muss ehrlich
im Iran eingesetzt werden schau mich
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch unsere
bildreporterin
[Musik]